you know maybe building this statue for  that alone he woke up in his neighbor's  right now holidays we've got the  Kilmer's in willows dough  Oh what about vally Kilmer's in that  willows oh he was mad Marty Kinsey there  was in that medieval toboggan  Kilmer's in the Saints my man my man was  like and he was like and it I see that  one just the cover look at Delsea know  what I'm realizing right now for the  first time is like if there was a graph  of Rd square and vally Kilmer's careers  yeah yeah RT square would start down  here right vally Kilmer's will be  starting right up here and RD square  would get this trajectory right in there  vally Kilmer's beyond this trajectory  right here like miss rice and just make  any movie sickening losses get a little  crazy little drugs make it still making  movies and then they meet at this point  in the same movie which is why the best  movie of all time is kiss kiss  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]